thank thank you John I'm simply in awe
of Carnegie Mellon I'll tell you why
1965 Allen dual Alan Perlis herb Simon
created modern computer science right
here that's the facts how do I know it
Google told me I also know it because in
the early 1970s I worked with them so I
have some some actual experience as well
this place for some reason was the
center of more innovation and wealth
creation then has occurred in many many
decades in America I don't know why but
I know it's true and it's important that
you succeed for the next hundred years
with this phenomenal new president of
course if we continue the narrative
school of computer science was
established under my mentor Jim Morris
Randy Bryant now lots and lots of
interesting things about machine
intelligence machine and learning
robotics and as part of my belief in the
importance of Pittsburgh and Carnegie
Mellon we created a development group
here of some number of hundreds of
people which is generated at least 30 or
40 billion dollars of profits for the
company I'm in awe of that too so when I
think about this place it's a it was a
mythical place of achievement and the
labs here we're not just for
experiencing research they were where
the future was dreamed up and where it
was created and so now we have a new
leader who is the perfect combination to
lead us forward here the background
Berkeley MIT National Science Foundation
where all interesting research get
started it seemed to me and now here
what's interesting about
our energetic new leader is he's also
testament of why we need to be an open
country to get extraordinarily brilliant
people to come into our country and
change our country and build our future
dr. Suresh so
they always say time changes things but
you have to change them yourself and
that's a direct quote from a tartan that
that I know a little bit about and in
this campus a lot have sat in this
building a lot of people are and this
school is renowned word wild obviously
for the computing work and engineering
work that we're talking about but let's
not forget that the School of Drama is
celebrating its 100th year in 2014 that
the School of Music's celebrated its
centennial in 2012 that the school of
applied arts was part of Andrew
Carnegie's original plan for the
University right alongside training and
technology which all opened together
more than a century ago it's interesting
when you think about he could not
possibly have imagined that a hundred
years after this was founded the people
who were here created far more wealth
than he ever had isn't that interesting
so there are lots and lots of people who
I could have quoted to talk about and
I'm a computer scientist with obviously
have a bias but with 15 Nobel laureates
and the 10 touring Awards which is the
largest number of computer science top
awards in the country they say that time
changes things but you have to change
them yourself these are the words by the
way of Andy Warhol right student
inventor innovator in his own right and
I think it rings true today so so you
guys right from the freshman in the room
all the way up to the most distinguished
a faculty member everyone here is a
problem solver maybe that's the answer
to what I said maybe maybe it's it's a
slightly different attitude starting
from the founding of the university that
has both achieved greatness but also
achieved great impact very interesting
is it reproducible yes it will take a
hundred years so the good news I guess
is that right now there are even more
problems to solve them before and you
hear them a lot right so you're busy
right center of innovation and problem
solving it's right here joblessness
especially for the young economic
despair
ready that only seems to widen barriers
to education to opportunity to social
and political progress we hear this all
day if they're going to be solved
they're going to be solved here in my
humble opinion but these can be solved
and everyone in this room you know poets
and physicists engineers English majors
everyone has the power to solve them and
the power is with you now starting by
the way with what you have in your
pockets or your purses you might not be
studying tech per se but Tech is your
tool to change the future the power of
those computers that you can't carry
around with you unimaginable when
computer science was founded here 50
years ago right the power of a
supercomputer in your pocket you've
never had a situation where people had
this amount of individual power let's
let's harness the collective
intelligence of all those people to
solve all these problems and make the
world a better place now so the problem
of course is how do you solve these
problems you start with innovation it's
flourishing right pershing here and in
other places and what's interesting is
you look at the economics of took the
economics of development technological
invention has driven almost all human
progress in GDP growth so if you wonder
why we do what we do we are the source
the collective we of economic growth
well-being medical health culture and so
forth if you look back in history
between 5000 BC in the 18th century GDP
per capita as best we can measure it
more or less doubled over 5,000 years
since then in the past year it's been
growing up by a factor of 33 so it
really does matter starting with the
Industrial Revolution which you all know
a lot about because a lot of it happened
right here in Pittsburgh so you hear
people say oh ok well it's different now
it's absolutely different now the last
500 years is not correct technology is
reducing the need for human employment
but there's no direct line from
innovation to real jobs the only problem
with that quote is it's false I'm in
aside from that's a nice quote
so people have actually studied this
there's an italian economist whose name
is Enrico more repti who's found that
for each new high-tech job in a city
five additional jobs are ultimately
created outside of high tech right so
and you see this in the tech boom that
has been going on here for a while
skilled occupation lawyers teachers
nurses and unskilled ones as well so
technology in this form is a driver of
economic and social gain it's not a
hindrance now it's true of course you
have all this knowledge literally at
your fingertips but just because we know
more than we used to doesn't mean our
problems go away so it turns out that
the knowledge that you have the fact
that you know this does not actually
cause it to get fixed you actually have
to take an action it's it's interesting
that the future doesn't even have
doesn't happen right it happens because
you know that in it for engineers the
future is not etched or written or coded
somewhere there's no algorithm or
formula that sex technology will do X or
Y technology does not work on its own
it's just a tool you are the ones who
harness its power so when I think about
how we're going to address the multitude
of issues that we face globally and
things in general are going pretty well
globally in terms of health growth wore
those sorts of things it's going to
happen because people like the people in
this room but more importantly the
current and future students of the
institution led by dr. Suresh will in
fact be the mechanism that will in fact
not just drive a better world for
themselves corporations knowledge
research medicine peace literature art
all done in this context I think the
best place to do that is right here
because technological innovation is not
just a line in the syllabus it's
actually in the DNA of the organization
again it's just there you take it for
granted you don't realize that you're
exceptional
I'm here to tell you that this is a
place that births global progress if you
will this is a place that can hate shape
a society like the ones think of this as
a new society with shared norms and
values across all of this so and i said
before computers can do amazing things
I've spent my whole life in this thank
you very much for inventing my field
again it could not have happened without
you andrew carter you would never
imagine the power that people you have
in your hands now these computers right
we work on they have speed they have
memory that is intricately complicated
wiring and unfathomably complex secure a
circulatory but what they don't have by
the way is they don't have a heart all
right you hear about technology taking
away jobs but until it takes away our
hearts which is not going to you will
only serve us to help help us to help
others right it helps us to assert to
solve problems to help other people and
make the world genuinely a better place
I'm really an optimist on this so the
digital ties that bind humanity together
the one that you're building now are not
possible without technology but it's
also not possible without us and by us I
mean you not just the people here but
the people that you train the people
that you lead this is not going to be
easy but as your fellow tart and said
time does not change things but if
there's any group thing can do this led
by a new president right a great leader
for a great institution it's now time
for you to go out and change things
yourself thank you very very much and
congratulations doctor
you